foreign
[Music]
College of Medicine at the human genome
sequencing Center and today I'm going to
present our work
of a structure and calling map of course
945 hundredness individuals uh using
long read sequencing this work is done
together we've shown on SLAP at the
Fudan University
so why do we care about structure runs
about what our structures are structural
balance I often Loosely Define as 50
base per genomic alterations that can be
clustered or have different types in
terms of deletions duplications
insertions inversions and translocations
this usually cause a higher diversity in
terms of Facebook and smds while they
remain in lower numbers than smds on
their own compared between two different
genomes on the right side you see kind
of thematics about how we detect these
kind of structural balance or often be
detected by kind of secretaries where we
align two or more regions of the same
way to different regions
um on the genome or in different
orientations as they came out from the
sequencer and by the signal we can then
interpret the location so the start and
stop application of those structure
bands those are called breakpoint as
well as the structured variant type as
we said there are five different types
of it as well as the sequence function
and that allows us to interpret the
structure ones um
across different scenarios so like
structure runs are very often discussed
as being important with some different
aspects of medical or biological
research one of the very easy points to
look up about or think about is
evolution and we can talk about for
example key games and machine losses
across different members of the
population or across different
evolutionary distances and we and others
have shown that structure around so
sometimes playing an important role in
segregating these different species so
there's different subpopulations
uh more in terms of data College
medicine maybe in human genetics so it's
very important to take structure balance
into account for genomic disorders here
I'm just showing you a structure event
map across the skbr3 breast cancer cell
line where it has multiple connections
between the different parts of the
chromosomes indicating uh important and
and less important
genomic alterations of this first cancer
cell line that lead to a percussion
but also the important thing an
important role in other diseases despite
cancer for example mendelian diseases
where we often look at additions
interpretations they know what to a
certain patient or a more complex
diseases like adult disease and
cardiovascular diseases so this is risks
um as well as neurological feces
and that brings us to the thread box
which is the impact of structure runs on
regulation clearly and easily to think
about this part is when you have a
deletion or duplication of certain Gene
and how this impact the transcription
and therefore maybe also to a
translation rate of this particular gene
into protein concentrations
and then last year on the bottom on the
bottom right we have measured the impact
on terms of phenotypes of structure and
clearly this is kind of Cherry Picked
but what I'm showing you here actually
the impact of different structural types
in terms of heritability and the y-axis
across different phenotypes on the
x-axis and here it's just phenotypes
that have been impacted by this
structure around across 25 or more so on
right you see uh the impact in terms of
copy numbers in red and black you see
the impact in terms of rearrangement and
in this grayish color you see the impact
in terms of smds and only when we take
the full complexity of a genome into
consideration we can really resolve or
again much more knowledge about certain
traits and certain phenotypes and how
the genomic component interacts or
influences this measurements
um just as a reminder for example
Parkinson's disease which is one of the
hard processes adult diseases I think
are currently described for only 15 or
20 percent of heritability that is
completely explained
um which is as you can see on the y-axis
just 0.5 which is much slower and one
reason for that could be actually that
um the the that multiple variants are
interacting in this um in the type of
Parkinson's disease that are hard to
identify and hard to put together in
associations
but really what we want to talk today
about
um is is how this uh
how this detection of the structure
variants is related to the technologies
that we have so like in 1940s and 1980s
we had kind of scary typing which
revealed to us uh different chromosomal
or chromosomal arm duplications or
losses but then really efficient you
know like microarrays you've got to find
a resolution of Gene duplications of
Gene losses uh using this microwave
Technologies but then
automotively in 2007 and 2008 we started
with high throughput short read
sequencing or DNA sequencing with former
tonsil lectures and obviously in the RCs
aluminum machines
that are producing this incredible
detailed pad entries
um that lead to an explosion of of
genetic variations in our ability to
study them across human genomes but also
other organisms
and then in the last couple of years
really I would say like in the last
three to five years quite frankly uh
we've seen Advanced and Boundary
Technologies such as the
biosq42 that have that Cambridge produce
hypothality rates Hi-Fi reads with an
incredible accuracy of like 15 KP to 20
KP lane or with Oxford nanopore I'm just
showing here minion machine for like
commission small but we are using the
study here that can produce very long
reads uh River Rock Symmetry and error
rate between three and eight percent and
upcoming updates even lower than this
and these two machines really enabled us
to get a better characterizations of
these important variant type of
structure rounds and also learn more
about the measureness and more about the
interactions with different in with
respect to different phenotypes
my group and others have started this
interaction and and the detection
possibility of structure runs deeply and
together with the myth genome on the
bottle we produce this nice paper uh
last year put out this nice paper last
year that showed the first kind of high
quality Benchmark for structure rounds
on the human genome a very characterized
insertions and conditions
um leveraging multiple Technologies in
the Ashkenazi Trio and as you can see
depending on the technology and
depending on on the methods that you are
using to detect this structure around
the detection rate varies above so we
kind of use this approach to bring
together using assembly as well as
mapping approaches to bring together
really a robot Benchmark set which tries
method development but also standard for
and then together with the FDA we
recently looked into the variability of
structured ones across different
sequencing events getting a better sense
of what we can expect in the field so to
speak across like within different
cohorts or within different studies for
example you can see that there's of
course the main variability in this
Matrix here is between the two parents
which is lcl8 and lcl7 and I'm
compatible to Children ourselves five
feet LCL six that are identical twins
basically but you can still see
depending on the methodology that we are
using in short rate structure ground
detection
um
you're having you're obtaining different
results and this is of course something
that you want to avoid and get better at
in the future
so
giving this to
um giving this two projects but also
others what we can really derived from
them is that language sequencing is
really improving the structures and
calling and detection and this can be
seen in multiple levels so first of all
we can see that the more comprehensive
we can detect The Experience out so in
long-grade studies and we often see
structure around counts of 20 to 23 000
structure rounds across human genomes
whereas short read studies often just
report something in the realm of 10 to
12 000 structural genomes and the
majority of differences here are really
insertions uh meaning like novel
sequences that are sometimes missed by
the shortly this knowledge itself or
they are hard harder to characterize
statistic knowledge you know using this
technology
furthermore when we use long tweets we
can assess repetitive regions uh more
broadly and more comprehensively across
the unit genome so one interesting paper
came out from index in 2019 identifying
193 medical genes they're short-termed
sequencing kind of falls short so to
speak and characterizing at least one
part or more of the axles of these genes
despite the fact that these are really
important and prominent genes in the
medical field here showing at the needs
of language sequencing and the improved
assessment of them these are including
prominent genes for example like LPA or
several HLA genes which are playing
important roles across cardiovascular
disease or immune deficiencies or cancer
and then the other construction that is
really worth mentioning here is of
course the t2c Consortium that is going
to be coming up and there's also a part
from here in Liga in this session
where they can reconstruct the entire
century and telomerism really using this
language Technologies to have a
continuous overview across the entire
chromosomes which is really fascinating
and really kind of the next uh Next
Level so to speak compared to what we
have right now in our reference genomes
is 38 and and gsh 387
um and that also is possible because
long reads improve the assembly quality
um of our samples at hand that we have
so we we can improve continuity which we
can measure over the M50
um therefore we also have less gaps so
unresolved regions in our assemblies and
nowadays there's more and more a trend
that we actually also apply phasing in
this
assemblies to accuracy reconstruction
two different Hydro types so giving all
this kind of advancement
of Technologies and like the technology
is also continue to advance in terms of
higher yield and therefore lower costs
um and software advancements either for
my group or from other groups you can
really see this kind of trend emerging
of having more and more long read-based
population sequencing well in general
language based sequencing going in this
chart we put together uh chart shows you
the number of samples across different
studies across basically the past three
years from start of 2019 to start of
2021 and here each stock just represents
a study with five or more genomes done
with long reads and we characterized
here in the size of the thoughts that
different genomic sizes so like you can
see in the beginning
um it was a lot of it was a few small
teams
um that has been processed for non-breed
sequencing or used language sequencing
for to obtain a comprehensive insight
and nowadays you have really kind of
this explosion in the late 2020 and now
obviously going to 2021 of studies of
human genomes or Human Genome sites
um
uh organisms using either assembly or
read mapping approaches
so how does this all relate to the topic
of today's
um Talk uh to kind of investigate
structural violence in the Hansen's
population well in like early
um or late 2019
um I was visiting the group uh control
fan at the Fudan University and I was
fortunate enough to be invited and give
a talk
um about my research and that of course
led to an opportunity to sit down with
his crew and think about what I've
probably
collaborations that we can start and and
common interests and one of the one of
the few heads about that was kind of the
obvious point the trch 38 is not enough
and so what we mean was not enough is
like the grch38 is clearly just one
representation
um kind of scrambled together across
different individuals that represent the
linear sequence and for that kind of a
great mechanism and itself as well as a
coordinate system however thinking about
different ethnicities
um either hunch and knees but also of
course Africans or others and it's clear
that this genome is lacking a lot of
information that might be either
not that it might be either private to
Asians or just not represented in this
location by a Stratford
and so uh it was clear that something
had to be done
um because like the hunter knees is one
of our largest ethnicities it's 1.4
billion people
um from the submissive Zone there is no
clear structure around Canada and only a
future non-reference genomes of high
quality assembies are available to
represent this population and so we
really kind of settled out to do this
um and and had this ambitious plan to
sequence 1000 individuals with language
sequencing to really study and be able
to study Evolution on medical
um reasons for using the Structure brand
map and across the genome
for the baby did this was
by look by sampling or taking a cohort
set that was really Central in in the
Han Chinese population and in fact they
actually required that all the samples
that we are sequencing have been for
three generations or longer in this
District of China and if we use the
Oxford manual performation system to
sequence these samples so basically you
run one flow cell per sample
and then uh on the on the tool side we
use uh different tools that my group and
I developed which I just want to go
through very briefly so for mapping the
uh for mapping the reads back to the
glch 38 platform uh we used ntmlr
um here I'm just showing you one
screenshot and one of the motivations
why we use this tool despite that we
developed it of course that here we
might be a little bit biased
um so here's actually screenshot you see
the different feeds which is each one
line uh coming from left to the right
and you can see nicely indicated that
there's a homozygous deletion indicated
by this black lines and in the top you
can actually see as well the drop of
coverage in the specific region
so ntmlr is kind of a nice method to
align this long reads and accurately
identify the breakpoints as well as the
structures only type that is present in
certain regions
then for calling we use sniffles
sniffles is a tool that I developed
um back in my postbook and going into my
faculty position into Baylor
um it has a sensitivity of around 88.7
in the position of 85
um giving this coverage levels that we
are using here in the study
um here on the right side I'm just
showing you an overview about different
benchmarks based on simulated data uh in
short the more clean the better it is
and the more precise it is and then you
have yellows in the case uh doing
indications of these correct structural
landfalls this can be like in accuracy
and break point
um or interest in the duplication base
here we have small duplications will be
reported as insertions actually
and this is what we compared it to we
compared it to shortfeeds which is the
first row of labeled Survivor
um where you can see that we are lacking
here lots of insertion force on the top
on the on the left side
um and also some characterization of
small events
uh but then however youth Survivor and
the reason why we use survivors we have
to compare structure around the merge
different VCF files for each individual
and how survival does that is by
comparing the break points as well as
the type of the structure around that
has been inferred and based on the break
points and the type it allow us to merge
two or more structure around together
across different VCF files and create
this population ECF file so those are
kind of the entire main pipeline for the
identification of structural so first
mapping the roots of ntmlr calling their
structure around based on these mappings
using sniffles and then creating it from
going from an individual VCF to
population DCF using Survivor
the other thing that was necessary to
obtain accurate calls was also a
genotyping approach of the structure
around so on the right side I'm showing
you here the reason for that so our
samples that we see from where On
average around 15x coverage plus the 15x
coverage which of course is not a lot
but we are speaking about early days of
model for quite frankly
and hard hard to manage samples
so in the Green Dots here represent the
structure around cause that we could
obtain by the previous pipeline by just
draw by just the noble calling this
structure around and giving that
coverage values and we can see here the
kind of an indication by the slope of
these points
um that there is a bias meaning that
lower coverage samples tend to have more
lower numbers of structures identified
however what we also implemented in
simplest is a geotype approach which has
been reported also in benchmarks by
others to be 82 accurate while
genotyping almost 100 of all the
structure rounds that you can do and
using this approach we can recover these
samples here indicated by this ground
dots so you can see with this ground
dots with genotypes and this is means
like we go back in the individual band
files and look for all the structural
answering the population file
but that really diminishing
um or completely getting rid of this
buyers instead of that is due to the
lower coverage in certain samples
clearly the downside of this approach
is that we might have missed some of the
private or very rare alleles in the low
coverage students
um
so when we look when we look into this
data set uh what did we find about what
do we see well in total across the 945
Han Chinese
um population we identified around 96
000 structure rounds 97 000 structural
times
the vast majority of which is conditions
and insertions this is an agreement with
previous studies that has been published
and then only a very few duplications
transportations and inversions
on the right top side I'll show you the
counter structure runs versus the length
distribution across different types and
like as indicated you can see the
different and important Peaks that we
like to see also based in other studies
which is like a large aloe Peak for
insertion Integrations laboratory in
green and orange
and then as the AP and the line to get
around 6 TB is right
um You can also see a handful of
multiplications of merchants
um in this kind of smaller
um smaller size of structure
what was interesting for us and that led
to a couple of speculations was actually
that the insertion versus Venetian wave
is just about one
uh which previous Studies have been
reported a little bit larger but it's
just about one for the population level
and then when we look at individual
levels it's kind of getting through
again that the numbers of insertions are
much higher than the numbers of
Divisions and this is kind of an
interesting observation uh at least from
my point of view because like this
handful of the spot on the right side
that we see that insertions seem to be
more frequent in the population or more
often shared in the population than the
deletions alone
and previous Studies have been
sequencing a very diverse samples quite
frankly for example as an IPS group has
published now two or three papers and
the last one just released between
science which I encourage I want to
check out but basically there they focus
on the large diversity set of different
ethnicities and Report similar levels of
the insertions much higher in deletions
however in our data set we focus on just
one ethnicity obviously
and there we saw this kind of insertion
deletion ratios of around one on the
population level
um next it looks of course where to
restructure runs fall along the genome
across this population as expected and
most of them are failing in interchanic
regions around 85 percent of them to be
precise or intronic or non-coding RNA
regions
um and then only very few are actually
intersecting with exonic regions or are
precisely near genes or at utr regions
we also compare our structure around
cause cause that
um with previous studies
um here we found
um
actually an overlap small overlap on the
short read studies of 1kb 1000 CMS
approaches it's normally and then
actually interesting a similar High
overlap response with the download all
study that has occurred I think 2020 in
itself from having Michael's less
and then like the largest overlap maybe
not surprisingly identified the CB bar
which obviously holds structural
encounts across many many different
samples but still in our study around 51
52 of all the structurals can be
considered novel and haven't been
observed before uh compared all to all
these different data resources that we
screened for
and this highlights of course the power
of these long bead approaches to
identify not just other insertions but
also identify structure random things
challenging repeat regions that are
often masked out by other studies
against further confidence in our
structure around cause that they
actually did this nice exercise here
where we use a three typer so a c-type
with a genotype of a structure ground
again going back into the bump files and
into the read alignments and identifying
if any reads or supporting the certain
structure around
for short reads and we use this as we
typer together with 100 illuminum
Chinese samples from the human genome
sequence are from the human genome
structure around variation group
and produce this kind of bar chart here
on the right what has been taking
account is again like you doing this
approach to comparing the long reads as
to because of short read data is not
very trivial quite frankly and we have
been previously published in years to
paper on the bottom left previously
publishing paper kind of assessing the
rate of success of doing this
so on the right side I'll show you here
that genotype rate meaning like what can
what is the typo was able to genotype
versus their least frequency in our own
course right and what you can see from
the results the genotype deletions
applications and inversions because if
the title was impossible wasn't able to
tune attack insertions
and what we can see here is very
interesting so
when we have structure balance for
example deletions here on 0.0.1 percent
of Allure frequencies among these
um of course they are not very often
genotype in the 100 data sets of
Philomena right but when we increase the
frequency of these structure runs in our
language and x-axis we see clearly an
increase of the genotype rate indicated
in the y-axis across the shortness and
this kind of increase makes a lot of
sense to us because like with the higher
Rd frequency of a of an S3 the highest
the probability that this is me is
actually carried also in another hunch
on this data
so overall this was kind of an
interesting side study aside
um slot that a boosted our confidence
into our structure bank at about because
like it behaves as expected that the two
allele frequencies are the new frequency
is correlated with the genotype rate
um and and that was also an interest
inside
so now we have kind of established the
structural and catalog it's still like a
VCS file this is kind of interesting but
and fine but like now let's let's dig
into this kind of biology and genomics
and what we can actually learn about
using this VCS file so the first thing
we looked at was where do these
structure run cluster across the genome
and of course we compared this also to
other studies to see what is novel to
our assessment versus to other states so
in total they identified 504 structure
and hotspots
um using a window size of a 100 KP and
when we do this of course we also wanted
to see if there's any poor enrichment
for certain terms the first thing we
observe obviously on the on the right
side is like a lot of svr spots that we
identified around the telomeric or
telomeres on different chromosomes but
there has been also a lot of non-century
or non-telomeric unstructural
hot spots and one of which is obviously
here in E chromosome 6 which highlights
obviously the HLA Locus which we know
should be there because like this is a
highly diverse book was important in the
immune response for humans
and therefore undergoes a lot of
structure around
it should be present in every study
um when we do the go enrichment across
this 504 hotspots of svcc sells the cell
signaling like Silicon processing
keratin filament and remove the related
responses for example this HLA locals
and chromosome 6.
uh next week kind of dig deeper a little
bit and see how this overlaps to
previous studies so again like this 405
SC hot spots actually interestingly 227
of them overlap with the downward alt
paper
um from 2020 or 2019 for that Microsoft
and I'm saying that interestingly
because like here they use only a few
genomes including like one or two
um I think I'm trying these genomes and
assembled the these instruments to
detect these structure grounds an
interesting because when we compare it
to the 1000 genome data set or the
numerous view data set which in numbers
of genomes have a much higher number of
individuals represented however using
short reads or for example in Thousand
synonyms project using low coverage then
we see that overlap is actually
diminished actually again pointing to
the fact that long we make a huge
difference here
and you can see this nicely on the Venn
diagram on the right side where we
compared the different intersects and
overlaps and again like if you look at
technomorously versus 2000 machine data
set these are kind of wide uh in this
agreement with each other whereas the
two long based studies um autonomous
people as well as ours which of course
there's much more many many more samples
are actually much higher if we move to
each other here around 160.
um directly overlapping and just private
between the two long studies
so the other thing we looked at well of
course actually deserts and with asset
definitely mean here
um features of the genome that have been
best that absorb that mutations can
expect so like highly conserved regions
for that purpose we also looked at the
kind of Highly conserved score uh the
fast score
um across the genome and we can see that
this kind of regions where we didn't
identify structure them have indeed all
the significantly higher
um
imitating the conservation I'm not
highly limited regions in these regions
so next again like we were interested in
the biology behind this right so like
what can we learn from these as we help
spots
um and what can be relevant for this
home Chinese population for this one
interesting thing that we could find uh
with this hot spots was uh the Amy Locus
um the email Locus is a well-known Locus
for human adoption in high starch diet
which means obviously rice and B planets
which have two high starch grains that
is heavily consumed uh in the Hampshire
news population
and here we identified multiple
specifications highlighting this laws as
a as the hotspot which is actually
private to our study and hasn't been
identified in other studies so far
um one of the reasons why we think this
is the case because like for example
Africans will also have this kind of low
side
um like in amplifier mutated since they
also often have a high star Styles is
because in this particular case the
floor size is highly repetitive and so
shortly decided and again not map into
this Locus easily and identify this
variant easily however with us with our
studies the fight they're having lower
coverage we can clearly identify the
structure around the process also
um and the next thing what we looked at
was of course natural mock options so
these are important mutations since they
kind of completely knock out certain
genes
um across the genome in total in our
course that we had 15 800
positions 300 of them
um overlap supporting protein machines
and 217 of those were not previously
reported despite having a having a real
median and air frequency of 0 0 9 it's a
lot of them are obviously very private
that's what you what you would expect if
I think across such a data set
nevertheless cannot be identified 10
macro natural knockout Keys within a
lead frequency of above 10 in our data
set and they often responded to immune
response gene expression regulation
Olive Factory and oversight meiosis
which was kind of interesting CNN on the
top right here I'm just showing you this
plot
um indicating the difference between a
real frequency between the genetic uh
genomic uh regions and this Natural
Markets
and then
finally relevant and interesting again
this is why I'm highlighting them here
are the three natural knockout genes
that we found within a leaf frequency of
actually 90 or higher in our catalog of
structure rounds across this uh almost
1000 functions and this includes the
team 6x14
cmf 98 and CNS 493
um
which are highly uh maxed out in our
capital
next we want to see of course if we can
use the structure band catalog to
identify which structure events are
impacting certain traits or certain
phenotypes phenotypes
um across the population so for that we
actually use the
Epi Chipotle catalog to overlap these
structure grounds and to identify
overlap or close proximity of our
structure runs versus reported she was
um Snips and investigated like that so
288 structure months directly overlapped
with this GEOS catalog SMD so that's
been previously reported and 1099
instructions includes proximity meaning
less than multiple apart uh from lots of
these um she was attacks
a lot of people's information that has
been characterizing previously
and obviously we looked into this
um here on the left side we're giving
you
um the the measurement of impact across
different phenotypes and lots of these
have to deal with diseases or disease
risks or simply other phenotypes one of
the examples that I want to highlight
here is interesting so like this is a
small deletion
across Aitken
172 based meditation actually of X and
12 in Aiken is a mentioned that impacts
the human height the mutations of that
Gene has been highlighted to have
exactly this kind of
um impact as you can see here there are
two Snips associated with height and
body fat exactly at this local losses
um and the deletion that we identified
are actually quite common in the
population so it's 28 percent of the
Year frequency in RBC F5
um
when we zoom out a little bit from
exactly the spot where this tradition is
sitting uh to the entire Gene and
looking at what kind of other keywords
hits the obtain in the Stream it's like
getting clear and clear the importance
of acan in terms of human hate and human
body amounts you see here a lot of
different Snips
um indicating this
um from the from the cheers catalog so
when we use our deletion that we
identified again like around a 28
percent of your frequency to stratify
the height of our cohort
we can see actually a nice little
correlation so what I'm showing you here
on the y-axis is the height of the
individuals that we had in our study and
then like in red is when the in the
Willows don't carry that that deletion
in green is when the individuals carry
the heterozygous genotype of
distillation and improve it they carrier
homozygous deletion identification and
you can see a little bit of a
diminishing for the height of course
this is not kind of as clear as night
and day maybe because like everyone that
has been studying human hate both both
are created human haters are very
complex trait and is of course not just
impact but genetic factors but also
impacted by diets and other
environmental factors
so this was kind of curious to see that
uh the deletion that hit near
um reported she was hit from smds
actually recalculate
um this like nice height difference
across individuals another example when
it comes to human height but a little
bit more complex to interpret was this
interesting condition
um in the aatk uh Gene this is a 50 base
51-based vegetation
is actually enhances regulates uh VA
iap2o is trigger threatening and I'm
showing you here the kind of interaction
map in the middle of this plot
CA E2 has actually been Associated to
multiple phenotypes
um which I'll show you here
um which includes a behavior
neurological cardiovascular system uh
embryonic but also proven size of the
body itself excuse me
so giving this different impacts and
different phenotypes we again use the
height measurements of our cohort
to assess the impact of distribution
that we identified in this enhancing
and this regulation and you can see here
that again like a little bit of a
difference in the individual median
sizes I'm in the middle median
measurement of the of the body heat
[Music]
if the y-axis during the different
genotype of this position at the other
it's not as strong quite frankly but
like it's very interesting tourists
the very last example that I want to
highlight today in terms of of this
regard it's actually a 91 based division
91 based resolution a CD cd9
um it has an audio frequency of almost
40 in our data set
um
and had multiple implications for this
genius one
so this was kind of an excuse about how
these structure man impact uh several
important traits and potentially
important machines uh across glch 38
however as we started this journey the
question was initially uh what are we
actually missing in glch 38 and how a
human reference genome May should be
extended right
so the group back to this kind of
question
we assembled the unlike priest by using
fly and then took this context that we
obtained from the assembly and filtered
them against ncbi to rule out certain
contaminations to rule out
um other species in the process that
have to maybe assembled in the process
of taking all the other treats in this
sentence
so once you've filtered this context set
we we could use glass with a higher
density and
length threshold and could identify 851
of these contacts that we could still
map back to glch 38 and these are likely
representing regions
the little gaps are in the current
reference you know
um or maybe going into
telomeric or centromatic regions
but with that regard what was
interesting is we could align
1478 of the remaining context to the t2t
reference and I think this really speaks
the quality of the t2t references as a
potentially reference genome because
here we could anchor
um these context into criminal uh to
centromers and telomeric regions and
confirm that these contacts are likely
from this location
still there are a lot of different
contexts remaining from our assembly
that hasn't been of those assigned to 38
or to TTT
so next thing what we did was aligning
to different hominated species using
shoots for example gyms
um what's the motivation to identify
contexts that are actually historically
in the human genome but maybe not just
particularly presented in the human
genome as as its current version right
because like it's just represents a
mixture of different
uh humans
in a linear reference in a linear base
so a 689 of this project could have been
aligned to the hominids using plugs
um and then from the remaining we still
had 560 that we could still getting
anchors we're using our reads longer
short reads into glc38 and we'll be
presenting clearly completely novel
regions of the of the compared to the
reference genome
um we next took the assemblies that are
just got published on the science paper
from Evan icast group and used them as a
as a Target and there we could again
align a lot of a high number of these
context of almost 3 000 of these context
the remaining context
um could have been aligned to this
reference
because this was interesting because
these hgsv assemblies represent
different diversity groups including all
the 100 Chinese assembly
um and then the last measure we aligned
back the multiple short reads data sets
to this assemblies and could still
identify support of 745 of these
contexts but we don't really know where
to place them right now in the human
genome with respect to 38. and then 446
of the context that we assembled in
total
um are still remaining unidentified so
we are currently not here where they are
already should belong to didn't find
huge support
um or fairly should be placed in the
human reference genome
and maybe require some uh in the
traditional studies
so first this is a lot to take in but
like as we go from top to bottom
um we shaped off the 850 Point context
to 38 in the 1400 to the pwt and the
minutes and so on so forth so only 446
contacts remain unanswered very short
belong to
when we look at where to this context
Falls that's already eluded a little bit
most of them are falling into telomeric
regions so here's the leftover from our
mapping through the output lines in the
teacher team
um
respect chromosome arms and on the right
side is those context that they could
anchor uh using shortcuts so most of
them are falling in close to centimeters
or close to telomeres however there are
still several
cases where they actually fall in the
middle of the of the chromosomes
indicating novel reaches that are highly
likely to carry the certain machines and
are important
the other thing that I found very
interesting that's why I want to spend a
few minutes here is
The Hominy thing so like here we put a
line as I said like 689 into chimpanzees
and then like smaller and smaller
fractions of these contacts also the
gorillas or an opens in one in general
like different monkey Cyclery different
packs and this follows of course the
evolutionary distance in terms of
genomic Evolution
um from humans to different uh
Humanities and monkeys
um indicated by this is treating
um so what is the like for example here
we see on the top on the bottom left a
screenshot from UCSC uh tuning browser
um in brown you have the Assembly of
chimp that black bar here is then the
conflict that we assembled from our
unmap three that's beautifully aligned
uh to the chimp reference you can see
hopefully a few differences between our
contact and the chin because like
obviously we are assembling this human
context they're not gym context right
however it's really the fascinating part
is that this context uh when actually
investing in Palestine we look at the
lift over files from the chimp to the
human genome and the human genome here
is in pink you see there's a huge gap in
the human genome for this region which
exactly represents the location uh where
our context from our hand Chinese data
set fits in right so this kind of
confirms so to speak
um the absence of this sequence in the
human genome 38 or 37 of or others
therefore
um but due to the alignment and the lift
over to the chimp confirms with this
region actually could be a human
reference uh human human genomic
location
that should be represented in 38.
um we could be investigating currently
this context closer we don't think that
they are unique or or specific to the
Han Chinese ethnicity you just
um short reads derived from other
ethnicities from the hdsp group obtained
from the htsv group which confirmed that
these context that we identified are
actually better representations of the
of the diversity of the human genomes
across multiple ethnicities
so with that actually I want to kind of
summarize the the positive so what did
we find and what did we learn
um well we identified a lot of Novel
structure events in our current study of
the 1000 Han Chinese
individuals using optional monopods for
sequencing
um we could identify that what was
interesting for me at least personally
that we observe a similar ratio of
insertion conditions on the individual
level compared to previous studies
however when we see it on the population
level these insertions
seem to have a higher near frequency
um compared to the individual level
therefore the ratio of insertions and
conditions is moved
um we could see that structure balance
and the hotspot have multiple phenotypic
implications or impact I showed you the
amylo locus which was previously
reported for Sarge bias where we
observed multiple duplications in our
data sets that were actually private to
our data sets just because this mosa is
highly repetitive and therefore
inaccessible for multiple other shortly
studies
um and that and I also showed you a
couple of stories with structure around
directly impact
um certain machines responsible for
height
and then lastly
um very interestingly I think we showed
you certain biases in the trch 58
towards ethnicities maybe that's not
surprising enough but we could really
assemble using this this that we could
assemble context and therefore genomic
locations that we can confidently assign
to the human genome
that are either represented for example
partially by the TTT Consortium however
also by other genomes representing
higher diversity of the human genomes uh
and and ethnicities
and some of them can actually also play
to place in the homily
um state or different apes or different
monkeys indicating that we're actually
despite having a long history of having
a high quality reference genome for
humans
um but still lack a lot of
representation of different ethnicities
in respect to this reference
uh in terms of tools what did we use we
used like semable R which is a long bit
mapper and has a very precise way of
aligning this long Clips because it
refuses to come back to get cost model
and then they were splitting these reads
uh it's really available here on this
GitHub uh and we use this together of
Sniffles suppose it's a structure band
called of the laundry
can identify all different types of
structure mounts including all the next
little complex functionals and it also
allows us to genotype the structure
lines across the population and together
with
Survivor which is kind of a toolkit for
merging comparing filtering structure
mounts allowed us to produce kind of a
square of vcforce structure and they're
spread off I mean that we have reliable
genotype calls across every structure
around across every individual
and if you're interested in these three
tools there are two Publications out of
my group being in nature method for
nature Communications uh very detailed
with tools and how they work and
heuristics
so this brings me to the acknowledgments
so I of course want to thank let roots
for giving me the opportunity to present
the bird here and today I hope everyone
will try to talk I really have to
acknowledge my team and my colleagues at
the University of Sequencing Center of
Baylor College of Medicine and channels
funding from NIH
um on the on the and this work wouldn't
have been possible quite frankly
um it was an awesome collaboration uh
with Sean's uh group from verban
University so here it's just one uh one
photo of us having a barbecue in
Shanghai which was very interesting
um and like yes so lastly my cook is
always on the lookout for for new
talents with postdocs or PhD students so
please just feel free to reach out or DM
me
um over Twitter and with that I thank
everyone for their attention I'm happy
to take any questions